はい 次に感情について勉強しましょう
なんでみんな感情悪くないとそんなにもう大きい声で叫んでいるのかということで
感情って何なのかということを勉強した方がよろしいんです
それからものすごく話難しくなるんだから
よくわかると思います
逆にですか？知らなかった
私は難しいものはわかりやすく思っていたんですけど
感情は大したエネルギーです
感情っていうのはものすごい
ものすごいエネルギーなんです
このパワーでみんな苦労を変えるミスを生きてるんです
この理性で生きてるんじゃなくて
感情のエネルギーで生きてるんです
例えば仕事に行く人々はね
私の仕事は人の役に立ってるんだからね
行かなくちゃいけないんだと
全然そう考えてないでしょうに
行かなかったらクビになるんだ
ちょこっと遅刻したら
ちょっともうもう何て言いますか
あのちょっと面子が立たないんだ
一番大事なことはね 収入がなくなるんだ
だから自分の見栄やらね
見栄があるんだから もうできるだけ早く遅刻しないで会社に行きます
それから仕事がないにも関わらず
もう退社しないんですね
退社というか この帰ってこないでずっといるんですよ
そこでまた早く帰ったら
どこかの飲み屋さんでね 10
時半まで11時までいて
やっと電車に乗って家に帰って自慢するんです 1
日忙しい すごい疲れたんです
理性ないんです 向こうに
ただ感情 そこでそんなに疲れるんだったら
あんたその仕事辞めてそこら辺で畑でも作ったらどうでしょうかと
それ嫌なんですね 収入が足りませんだからね
だから結局は感情で生きてるんですよ
それも確かな事実なんです
感情だからもう苦労っていうのは気にしないんです
例えば戦争をしたければ
大量殺人したければ 自爆テロをやりたければ
感情を引き起こす 起こして興奮させればいいんです
簡単でしょ 戦争をやる場合は
理性っていうのはひとかけらも使わないでしょう
あれこれと嘘を言って言って興奮させるんです
感情を引き起こすんです
誰でも自分の体に爆弾をつけちゃってね
自爆テロしたいんですかね
だから子供を選ぶんですよ
自爆テロの場合 もう若者っていうのはもうすごい理性主義でしょ
あれって理性主義じゃなくて感情なんです
え？理想主義主義 あれって感情なんです
世の中で完璧な世界あるわけじゃないし
正義っていうのはあるわけじゃないし
でも若者はもうなんとか自分が頑張れば
こんな大人が作っている不公平な世界をね
なんとか直せるぞと思ってるんです
直せません 本人たちも大人になると同じことだからね
しかし 若い時は理想主義で理性はなし
一番感情が激しく動いている時なんです
まあ自分の国でもテロリストがいるんですけど
日本の新聞では大変褒めてますけどね
もう記事があってね むちゃ褒めてるんです
で あの 12から14歳の子供たちを全部もう奪う
もう誘拐して軍隊に入れるんです
テロリスト 全部子供 それはアジアの子供たちだから
ものすごい もう体が小さくて成長していないし 12
歳で言ったっても 日本の12歳の子供みたいに背が伸びちゃってとかね
それはないんです 日本の子供と比較すると
大体まあ 8歳ぐらい の体格ですよ
ああいう子供たちに軍事訓練させちゃって
もうむちゃくちゃ残酷な人々だと思います
で 理由は調べてみたら
もう残酷っていうのは子供には知らないんだ
ということなんだ だから恐ろしい
精神的にイカれた人々にとっては
一番いい兵隊さんたちなんです
18歳になってから正式的な軍隊に入って
正式的な訓練を受けている人々にとっては
まあ恐ろしい敵を倒すことだけ教えてあって
子供に向かって鉄砲を撃ちなさいとはないんだからね
シビリアンは回らなくちゃいけないんだから
だから負けるんです 爆弾やら機関銃やらこうやって持っていても
相手がもう自分の子供と同じ子供だからね
鉄砲でないんです 正式的な軍人はどうでも
そういう風に訓練はやらせないんです
やらせちゃうと国際法律違反だからね
誰でも構わず殺せという軍隊じゃないんです
敵国に行っても 子供やら女性やらシビリアンのできるだけ損害ないようにするのは
軍隊の正式的な軍人のやり方なんです
軍人を殺す 攻撃してくる人々を殺す
それだけ だからこの すごいパワーなんですよ
感情っていうのはものすごいエネルギーなんです
どんなものもさせられますよ
それほど危険なことじゃないんだけど
無意味な役に立たない品物を高額で売りたければ感情に話しかけるんでしょう
コマーシャルって何でしょうかね
微妙には理屈はありますかね
でもコマーシャル見てください
なんかえらい人気のある女の子やら
もう可愛く振りもう売っちゃって
もうなんとか品物見せてそれで終わり
この品物はこういうものだから価値があるんだよっていうことはゼロなし
あのコンピューターの富士通でしたか？会社がコマーシャルに木村拓哉くんを使ってるでしょうね
決まってて 何ももうすごいいいパソコンやっていう話じゃなくて
あいつが釘付け ドラマなんですね
そこでもう一人有名なタレントさんが来て
それで邪魔すると帰れと追い出すんですね
突きつけてるんですね
それだけ それでみんな書きたくなるんですね
やっぱりあれはもう いかに馬鹿にされているのかって
感情に訴えて だからこの世の中で人間がもう生きてるパワーが感情なんです
それをゼロにしようとしなさいと言ったら
誰も賛成するわけないでしょ
しかし 私は前言ったんですよ
これが極端に危険で あなたは死にます
理性がなくなるともう終わり
天国に行ったら 十七か三十人か数は覚えてないんだけど
バージンたちが来る 神様用意しているんだから
イスラムの若者は自爆テロやっています
それであの話題になったあの風刺漫画で
一つのコマがモハメドさんが
まあちょっと待ってよと
もうバージンはもうもうないんだよと
テロたちに言うんですね
プレーストップ ウィードンツハブイナフバージンというタイトルなんです
これにもう六十人以上死んじゃったんです
イスラム人が また教会のマスターたち
いかに無知で理性がないのか
それくらい漫画でイスラム教は壊れるわけがないし
人の文化を知らないことでからかったってもどうったことはないし
浅はかな文明のヨーロッパ人が私たちのアジア文明をどれほど馬鹿にしたかというと
だから言って殺し合いに行かなかったでしょう
それでアジア文化がもう壊れてクタクタになったわけでもないし
まあ自然の流れで変化はありますけど
理性があったらね 理性的に攻撃するんでしょうし
今思い出したのは この自分の国が植民地になっていた時代で
その時私はいることはできなかったんですね
五十年ぐらい前なんですけどね
あの あるイギリスの一般の人がね
もう まあそれなりの勉強した人でしょうと思いますけど
まあなんか植民地だからね
えらい格差があって 田舎者の審判をやってるんですね
だから戦災遺産 イギリスの財産という感じで
そこでどこかの土地がもうイギリス人にあげません
それはお寺の土地なんです
めっちゃ攻撃するんで
このお坊さんに それでイギリスの法律を言ったら
まあ国が欲しいと言ったら
あなた方には権利はない
全部土地我々のものだという態度なんです
それで裁判になっちゃって
まあこの人を裁判をやっていて
どう進めるか分からないんだから
通訳もついていて このお坊さんはかなりもうずるいんですよ
で 昔の王様からこの土地を自分のお寺にくれたという
なんとか証があるんです
そういうものあると だいたいスリランカ伝統では
それはずっとその他の人は取ることはしないんです
土地が必要だったら話し合って分けてくれと
すると状況を考えたら
はい どうぞと もう昔お寺にすごい土地があったんです
全部政府にも分けて分けてあげて
今ほんのちょっとしかないんです
あげた場合はすべてその上さんさんが自分であれを書いてあげるんです
法律で取ろうと言ったら
もうそれは無理 あげなさい
理性があるんだからね
法律は効かないんです
そこでこのお坊さんは
一応通訳をする人がいるんですけど
その人もキリスト教の人で
国のスリランカ人ですけど
もうなんとかなんとか通訳をしてあげる
そのお坊さんは証人頼んだところで
I'm パーリおじさん
じゃあやりなさいと すぐ
あのキリスト教の人わかるわけですね
もうどうにもできなくなっちゃう
だからあなた方には証拠あるのかと
土地は自分のものやというためにと言ったら
古いもうあれ資料を持ってきてね
全部読み上げる あれはシンハラ語なんですけど
古いシンハラ語で徹底的に研究して勉強していないと理解できないんです
それはどういう意味かというと
こういう意味だよ わからないと怒るんです
あんた方どれぐらいわからないのかと言っちゃうと恥ずかしいでしょう
これはわからなくてあんた審判したいんですかと
それを怒鳴るところはシンハラ語で怒鳴ったりして
それはちゃんと通訳もできるし
大恥かかれちゃったんですよ
その人に 審判はできなくてね
まあお坊さん勝っちゃったんですけどね
結局 でもあの裁判官も若かったんですけど
これは勉強しなきゃダメやと
いくらなんでもこの野蛮人が何言うものかと
で 勉強始めたんです このパーリ聖典協会設立したのはその人なんです
で 後で大教授になって
あのレイスさんって人と大量に本を書いたんで
パーリ聖典 もう死ぬまで英訳したんです
しっかりした学者になって
誰が勝ったんですかと
だから理性があれば何の力もなくなく成功するんです
だから戦うんじゃなくて
理性を使って冗談でからかいちゃえば
で 冗談言えばいいんですよ
からかいちゃえばいいんです
からかうために 冗談を言うためにはすごく理性が必要なんです
このアホマンコメディになりませんよ
阿呆を演じるためにはすごく頭が良くないとできないんです
そういうことで 感情っていうのは大変な危険という態度は態度は私は変えません
しかし そこ世間の態度っていうのはわかります
それが我々が持っている唯一の生きるエネルギーなんです
人を戦争にも出せます
誰でも死にたくないので
自爆テロをさせることもできますよ
感情に訴えればもう怖いもの知らないで頑張ってくれるんです
しかし 感情っていうのは理性の天敵です
欲 憎しみ 嫉妬 恨みなどには理性はありません
全然理性ないんです 理性の天敵なんです
例えば若者に なんであんたはあの子のことを好きですかと聞いちゃうと
いろいろ言うでしょ あれ全然当てになりませんよ
親切で可愛くて 活発で明るくてとかね
だから好きですよと あれって理屈ですかね
ということは その他の女の人々は親切じゃない
可愛くない 活発でない
怠け者 そこで嫌になったら
親切なところはもう随分勝手わがままやということにするんです
前は何でもかんでも まあこれどうこう
お茶どうご飯食べましょう
まあこれはもうそれが親切だと理解していたんです
親切だと まだ嫌になっちゃうと
自分が寝たいのに ちゃんともうこの時間ですよ
起きなさいとかね まあこれこれ食べなさいと言っちゃうと
もううるさい これわがままでとかね
同じこと だから理性ないんでしょうに
活発なところは気が強くてもうもう耐えられませんと
前は活発やって言っていたんですけど
だから この欲なんかには何の理性もないんです
怒りの場合も同じなんです
逆にこの怒りよく理性もどきで正当化すると
ものすごい危険なんです
正当な怒りなんかありえないんです
一番世の中はこの正当な欲よりも正当な怒りが正しいと思っていますよ
で ユダヤ教とイスラム教はものすごい厳しい
その取りにとっては  自分に損害与えたら
自分には誰か迷惑かけたら絶対忘れないで
それだけはやり返せと
自分の息子を殺したら相手の息子を殺せと
それはすごい それは道徳的なことであると
そこで相手の息子を殺す中で
家族みんな殺す まあそこはもう良くないんだと
だから我々はどうですかね
あんた方腰抜けるほど我々の道徳にというふうに
また自慢話です それで正当の怒りは正当化しちゃうと永久的に消えませんよ
正当化できない いい加減神の言葉ですというのは理由じゃないでしょうに
それはタムという まあという紙の文書をもらっちゃったんだから
ユダヤの方々はね しっかりしっかり書いてるんだ
誰も知るもんかね それは神の言葉か何かという
それだったらなんで神が世界を全部作っちゃって
ある一部の人間にだけそういう
証をあげるんですかね
まあとにかくこの我々はそういう宗教ではなくても
怒ったら理由つけるでしょうに
だってあの人をこうしたんではないか
だってこうしたんではないかとかね
それっていうのはものすごい危険で
もう人生終わりですよ
それだったら自分の怒りの感情で自分を蝕んで殺すだけに正当化するんじゃないんです
感情には理性がないんだから
正当化不可能なんですよ
チョコレートケーキ好きな人がいるとします
そこは何か理屈あるんですかね
ないんです ただ好き それ欲
それだけ もう一人はチョコレートケーキは大嫌いやと
もう色も嫌やという人もいる
それはその人の感情で
欲で理由はないんです
例えば卵は食べられません
アトピーがあるんだというのは
それは理屈です アトピーの子供たちはいくつかの食べ物は食べられないでしょうに
それは理性で それわかったのは
子供たちはそれを食べてみたところで
病症がひどくなっちゃったんです
本当は好きに食べてみたいんだけど食べられない
その場合は理性なんです
だから感情には理性絶対敵です
なのに我々世間では感情を正当化する
怒ったらあれこれあれこれって理由を言う
会社も途中で辞めちゃって
あれこれあれこれ言うわ言うわ言うわ言うわ
もう私の場合はもうかなりもうそういう失敗の人間ばっかり来て
あれこれ言うんだからね
もうもううるさいんですよ
だから私は理由捨てなさいと
理由を言うなよと 理由をつけて怒りやら憎しみやら落ち込みやら
そういう感情を消すことはできないんです
変な屁理屈理由をつけちゃうと
もうもうコンクリートみたいな感じで
強力なボンドでつけたような感じで
もう心から抜けなくなっちゃうんです
だからまず理由はない
もうもうどうしようもないんだと
もうこんな感情だと いい子は
それは事実だから私もわかる
人間というのは感情で生きるんだから
感情が衝動だから なるほどね
では頑張りましょうと
ゆっくりと いや そんなこと言ったって
あいつが悪いと言っちゃうと
私はきちんともうこの人は育ちがありません
ということになるんです
愛情 欲情 欲など なんで同じことをミス書いたかというと
これパーリ語ではミスなんです
まあ欲っていうのは普通に欲しいっていうぐらいのことで
愛情っていうのは普通の愛情で
欲情っていうのは これまたちょこっとおかしいというかね
ただの欲にもいろんなランクがあります
などの感情が現れたら
人は何をするかはわかりません
本人さえも たとえ結婚して 3人の子供がいても
誰かに対して欲情が生まれてきたら何するかわかりませんよ
世の中にあるでしょうに
時々もうたまに聞きますからね
そうやって不倫しながらもうじゃあ離婚したい
離婚はダメって言っちゃうと
そいつを殺しちゃうんです
それで子供まで殺しちゃう
目的は自分好きな女と一緒になるためなんです
そこまでやる やるんですよ
今まですごい優しい父親でいたんですけど
突然感情が別な感情が湧いてくるとどうするかわからない
だから母親は子供は殺すわ
山梨の他はね もう一切
子供を殴ったりして もしかすると失踪になるかもしれませんということ
両親が もう怪我出すんですよ
もう で 警察に言ったらもうもう泣き止めないんだと
これって人間ですかね
1歳  2歳までは子供はもうもうずっと泣いてるんだからね
それはそれ 子供は特定じゃないでしょうに
どんな赤ちゃんでももう泣くわ泣くわ
もうもう場所は構わず
どこででも そこで子供をぶん殴って
どういう風に殴るんでしょうかね
また赤ちゃんを 理性で考えると
これできるのかと でも感情だったらやっちゃいます
本当にもう赤ちゃんさえ
この感情のせいで安全じゃないんですよ
殺されちゃうんです だから子供は思考を使ってないんだから
この赤ちゃんでもね あの生命のエネルギーは感じるんですよ
生きるエネルギーだけ
なんで母親にべったりつくのかというと
あのエネルギーなんですね
母親の感情のエネルギー
それがすごく優しくて
自分を包囲してくれて
自分のどんなところも嫌なところも
何でもかんでも庇ってくれて守ってくれるんだから
もう母親にべったしになるんです
別に頭で考えてるわけじゃないんです
だから この言語が発達していない場合は
かなりコミュニケーションは取られています
それでああいう殴られる赤ちゃんたちでも
この親の波動を感じるでしょうか
この人は殺される そうすると愛情がないんだ
でも自分では逃げることはできない
置いたところばっかりで
だからお母さんでお父さんでもこうやって見ると
もう怯えちゃって すごく泣くでしょうね
あの悲しみというか あの苦しみを感じると
だからずっと泣いている子供でも
時々人を変えちゃうと
別な人が抱っこしてあげたり
慰めたりすると もうすぐ落ち着くでしょう
あれはこのエモーションのパワーなんですよ
ですから 感情っていうのは本当にもう完璧に危険です
理性の点で我々何するのかとわからなくなるんです
怒り持ちなどの場合も同じです
感情は破壊的です 家族は破壊するは
周りを破壊するは もう国を破壊するは
地球まで破壊する 感情は
何でも破壊する 自分自身も破壊しちゃうんです
例えば いろいろ例で考えましょう
権力が暴走した人々は独裁者になって人を殺しまくって
やがて自分自身も築いたものと一緒に破滅するでしょう
これ事実でしょう あっちこっちで独裁者が現れてきて
人は殺しまくっちゃって
自分の国の人々やら隣の人々やら
それから自分が政治やっている間でいろんなものを築くんだけど
全てと一緒にパワーが全部消えちゃうんです
一片もなる 破壊的ですよ
これは権力 欲 欲なんです
欲の感情 生命は弱いもろいもので
簡単に死ぬんです 生命っていうのは
体がでっかいんだからといって強いわけじゃないんです
ちょっとしたことでも
壊れますよ 死にますよ
ゾウとかね すごい体がでっかい動物いるでしょ
ちょっとしたことで死んじゃうんです
体弱いんです 特に飼ってるゾウの場合は
ゾウは何でもかんでも食べるっていうことじゃなくて
食べ物はちょこちょこっと変わっちゃうと
もうお腹が壊れるんです
壊すんです 自分が自分の子でゾウがいるんだから
もうみんな食べさせるものにはすごく気をつけるんです
ゾウも人間に付いちゃうと
もう人間の食べ物を食べたがるんですよ
で これすっごく好きなんですけども
ほんのちょっとあげる分はもうゾウ使いの人は黙ってますけど
もうゾウに食べれるぐらいを持ってきてと言って持ってけと
例えばケーキとかね ご飯とか
ご飯はこれぐらいだったらまあいいでしょう
あげてくださいと 大量に持っていっちゃうともうダメ
食べさせない ビスケットでも
まあ 1枚2枚だったらまあいいでしょうと
ゾウの口にビスケットって1枚2枚
ビスケットの箱を 2つ
3つ  4つぐらい一つ入れないと噛めないんですからね
でもあれ食べちゃうとお腹が壊すんです
だから私たちも風邪引いてもそうだが
すっごく気をつけるんです
大変です ですから この体がでっかいんだから力あるんだからといって弱いんです
面白いんですよ 人間も体がでっかいんだからといって
生命っていうのは誰でも弱いんでしょうし
すぐ死んでしまいますよ
それはよく覚えてほしい
なんでそんなことを言ったというと
感情のような恐ろしい毒に耐久性はありません
これを覚えてください
感情みたいな恐ろしい毒に
この肉体には耐久性がないんです
怒りが出てくると肉体はクタクタ壊れるんです
欲が出てくるともう全部もう壊れていくんです
健康も何でもかんでも
耐えられません 破滅することを不幸になることを避けられません
感情で生きていると 喜怒哀楽は悪くないと言っていられる場合じゃないんです
よくよく見ると 感情とウイルス似ていますよ
ウイルスに感染したらね
最大できることは感染者を殺すことでしょ
はい だから感情にもできる最大のこと
もっとできますよ 感情で死んじゃったら
次の生まれももう決まって不幸なんです
殺すんです 感情は 他人に移すこともできるでしょ
では 皆様は自分の知識能力を人に移してみてください
移りますかと 移ります
では 自分の怒りとか憎しみとか
簡単に移ります 子供はなんとか嫌なことがあって怒ると
お母さんも怒るんですよ
子供にどんな理屈かとわかりませんだけどね
子供は自分で何かやろうとして
おもちゃの遊びでも何でもうまくいかなくても怒っちゃって
もうあっちこっち物を壊したり引っ張ったり
いろいろなことをしていて
それは子供の世界の問題で
まあそこはまあこれでいいでしょうとかね
言えばいいのに なんであんたそんなことにそんなまで怒るの？で
移ってる だから怒り 憎しみ
嫉妬 欲 嫌悪などの感情っていうのはいたく簡単に移るんだけど
自分の能力 自分の知識
どうやって移ってあげるんでしょうかね
でも私も私の弟子 2人いるんですけど
この 2人は弟子じゃありませんけど
国で子供みたいでも可愛くてね
遊びたいんですよ でも自分の思考パターンというのは違うんですから
いろんなことを冗談やいろんなことを言いたいんだけど
なかなか国の言葉が出てこない時もあります
こうやって英語で言った方がぴったしはめますけどとかね
でもあの子 2人に英語を教えたりとかできないんですよ
英語で言った方がうまく言えるのにとかね
一人で悩んでるだけ だから知識やら能力やら
それは移してあげることはできません
かわいそうでしょ 人間の人生っていうのは
怒り 憎しみ 落ち込みの嫉妬だったら簡単に移るんです
感情っていうのはウイルスですよ
免疫力がある人はウイルスを退治して健康になるでしょ
ウイルスの場合は自分が免疫
免疫力を持たないといかんですね
感情の場合は理性が免疫なんです
感情を潰すためには理性というのが必要なんです
それで理性という免疫
怒り 欲 怠け 無知 落ち込み
引きこもり 引きこもりなどの感情は
冷静になることで理性になることで減るんです
落ち込みでも もうちょこっと冷静に物事を考えると消えるんです
怒りも冷静になれば消えちゃうでしょ
今 あの英語の COOL という言葉は最近別の意味で使ってますけど
普通なノーマルな英語だったら COOL DOWN という単語があるんですよ calm
down というのでもありますけどね
人が感情を抑えて COOL DOWN
COOL DOWN というんです
それで消えます あ そういえばあなたもうその通り
その言っちゃうともっともっとヒステリー
ヒステリーが 大きくなるだけなんです
怒り 欲のヒステリー パニックを起こしたらクールダウンする
calm down になる
落ち着く 冷静になる それが免疫です
人の人生は感情と正気の終わらない戦いですよ
正気っていうのはクールダウン
calm down ということなんですけど
そこで欲が出てくる うまくいかないと
まあちょこっと抑えましょうと
正気に戻る 飲み屋さんに行ったところで
すごい綺麗なお姉ちゃん見たところで
もう感情が出てきちゃうと
でもこれは良くないと
これは危険であると 自分には家族がいるんだと
家族を守るのは仕事じゃないかと
で そこでクールダウンになるんです
そこでやっと なんとか無事危険でない状態で終わっちゃうんです
命拾いみたいなもんなんです
だから普通の人間の人生っていうのは
この終わりない戦いなんですよ
感情で生きてようとするんだけど
これで芯がいますから
理性がまた引っ張ってくれるんです
それで死なないで済む
また感情で死のうとすると
また引っ張ってくる それでもう六十
八十年までいたということは
百年まで感情で生きたんじゃないんです
感情なら一日二日で死にますからね
その時その時の正気が人を守ってくれたんです
だから理性が免疫なんです
理性は本人と他人を守り
人生を成功させたり幸福にしたりするが
いつでも邪魔者扱いです
でしょ 感情が味方だと思っているんです
こんなに無礼な人間いるのかね
無礼というじゃないね
恩知らず 自分を守って
自分を成功させて 自分に幸福を与えてくれているのは理性なんですけど
喜怒哀楽の方が味方だと
喜怒哀楽は盲目で殺そうとしているのに
だからトータル的に言うと
人生はうまく進まないんでしょうね
敵が味方だと勘違いすると
もう生きていられないでしょう
国に敵国からスパイが来たと
諜報員が来たところで舞い上がって
この人こそ素晴らしいんだとかね
自分の味方を追いだ あんた方何言うのかと
いて 何でもかんでも見せたり押し出せると終わりでしょうに
しかし 人間っていうのは
生命っていうのは みんなもう恩知らずのいいところで
自分の味方 理性という味方が敵だと思っている
邪魔者扱いして 感情で生きていようとするんです
感情で大海感情っていうのは退化する人が生命として
感情が破壊的なので それほど成長することはできません
欲で怒りで人間は成長しません
そこでストップになるんです
理性で成長するんです
勉強したくない 遊びたいと思っちゃうと
それは欲なんですね 頭良くなるわけじゃないんです
自と他に不幸を招いて
自己...あ こう この自己じゃないんです
自己破壊になることで終わるんです
人生は 感情があると 感情で退化なんです
自己破壊することも退化でしょ
社会壊すことも退化でしょ
発展させません 理性が時々ブレーキをかけるならば
ある程度で持ちこたえるだけです
我々は 1 日にして自己破壊行きたいんだけど
例えば原子爆弾いっぱい作ってはりますよ
地球を破壊するまで それはもう感情で作ったもんで
しかし 理性が働いてブレーキかけてたんです
ちょこっと だから持ちこたえてはいるんです
感情に成長 向上 発展がないことは大事なポイントです
これが覚えておいた方がいいんです
感情の世界には成長 向上
発展はなしということ
退化はあるんです  こういう仏教のそういうこと
すごい難しいの 難しいポイント
今喋ってますけど 人が死後どうなるのかと
で 行いによって生まれるでしょうという仏教の転生論がありますけど
あれ 感情でわかりますよ
感情がすごいエネルギーだから
だから天国に行きたければ
感情を抑えて理性でいればいいんです
例えば 死ぬ時は体が壊れちゃって
痛くてたまらんと もうなんだこの痛みは
もう生きる気もないんだよ
ああいうこと この怒りに対して怒っちゃうと危ないんです
それで理性入れちゃうと
まあそんなもんやと もうそろそろ死ぬもんだから
気持ちいいわけないでしょうと
落ち着いたらもう死後は大丈夫になります
次に なんで感情っていうのはそんな人気者ですかと
これどう読むんですか？究極的なのに味方と思う人気者ですね
それは生きる衝動だからです
これで生きているんだから
我々のこと 命そのものなんですよ
感情が だから人気あるのは当たり前なんです
本当は究極ですけど 感情がないと人は何もできなくなると思っている
つまらない 次は味気ない
やる気が出ない 面白くない
力が湧いてこないと思っている
感情がないと面白くないよと
この人生は 毒の感情しか経験したことがない我々の考えは当たり前
あんなことを言っても
もうちょこっと戻しましょうか
この最後のつまらないとかね
喜怒哀楽なかったら超つまらないでしょとかね
味気ないでしょとかね
そんな偉そうなこと言えるのかと私が聞きたいんです
なぜならば 我々は毒の感情しか知らないんですからね
それはね 一生ファストフード食べてる人が
もう体にいい まあ手作りの
誰かがね 何か作ってくれたら
なんだこれ 味がないとかね
面白くないとか言っちゃうでしょ
あれ ファーストフードはもう人間食べられる
食べられるもので作っているわけじゃないんです
牛丼屋さんに行ったっても
これあの捨てる肉破片をもう逃がしちゃって作っているんです
食べられる肉は別に高いお金で売ってるんです
しかし ファストフードばっかり食べていると
これがもう刺激的で 味があっておいしくてたまらんと
誰かがあんまり塩を入れないで
醤油も大量に入れないで
もうちょこっと体に健康な食べ物なんかちょこちょこ取り出したり
炒めたりしてあげちゃうと物足らないんですね
そんなもん もっとひどいんですけど
我々は他の感情を知らないんでしょうね
毒感情しか だから毒感情しか知らない人は
喜怒哀楽がなかったら済まないと言ったっても気にすることじゃないんです
生まれつき目が見えない人は色存在しないというようなものなんです
生まれつき目が見えない人が色なんかあるわけないでしょう
美しくということはあるわけないでしょうと言っても
そんなに当てにする必要ないでしょう
ただ その人は知らないだけだからね
炭火の上で 2 3分しか歩けないということは
人に 2 3分しか歩けないという意味でしょうか？と私は聞きたいんです
人間が毒の感情という炭火の上で歩いてますよ
だから 2 3分でもう死んじゃいます
だから炭火の上に歩くということは
我々の普通の人生なんです
まあせいぜい人間にできることはそんなもんやと言っていいのかと
炭火の上ではなくて 美しい公園であること
2 3分のところじゃないでしょうに
ものすごい美しい庭園
公園とかね あって 大事な公園があるとしてください
歩けば歩くほどいろんなことを見つかったりして
何でもかんでも美しくて
そうすると 2 3分のところじゃないでしょうね
1 日終わって帰るときでももったいなとかね
もったいないと 公園に入る時はもう 11時になったんだからね
あれ  8時半でもう開園なのに
今度は 8時半に入った方がもっと遊べるんではないかとか思うでしょうに
だから感情の別なものもあるんです
だから私は言いたいのは
この炭火の上に歩くということはやめた方がいいんです
まあ一応ちょこっと休むという意味なんですけど
どうぞ